Hey nearly stripped ball deflected and
stolen by Durant
three-on-two the other way Durant goes
right by Liggins and lays it in and
they've been the best home team in the
league so far 15 and to Irving out to
love-love set fires in hit that's just
such a difficult action defense there to
stop them Irving fakes that's a team in
the NBA and they added one of the great
scorer skin at NBA history very scary
for opponents Oklahoma how sweet was
that both teams have had guys putting up
career numbers James with the steal on
the tops of pass drives a layup
named one and a foul yo babes one and a
foul play types and rushes up the floor
Durant quickly kill America with
authority stricted ballads we see Durant
on the previous possession in transition
dunking on loved plates Hopson rushes up
the floor Durant quickly to the basket
with authority love the outlet pass to
James
a lot of sick ones that was for those as
well
drives past Shepard stops pulls up and
scores
man that's your good
I mean this guy what a year he's Savin
what a career he's havin new faces for
the Warriors hits a pair of free throws
Golden State up six James behind the
back gets to the rim left-handed
switch to go behind the back and then
finish beautifully with the left hand
[Applause]
curry finds Thompson four seconds west
nice feedback the tops little banks it
in Melik gorgeous pass from David West
James Holden shot clock down to eight
mines fries
good patience and chanting try get to
dunk more reset my feet inside
excellent passing run the leading assist
team in the NBA / game right now rollin
state 31.3 obviously a long way to go in
the season deserving back extent of
beauty wing he's already had a couple
deflections today to save baskets
Tristan Thompson cleans it up and throws
it down ball poked away by curry my head
to Durant direct with Liggins in pursuit
throws it down curry quick catch and
release Steph Curry with his first field
goal from the field
Irving steps back finds Kevin Love quick
release on a free
his second three quarter rant with his
eighth rebound
Durant long three-pointer his first
three of the games 17 points now for
Kevin Durant
James double-team splits the defense
gets inside backs at home
[Music]
Cleveland has done this year love is in
such a comfort zone with this team in
his third year with him is Durant
answers back with a three Durant
fine Steph Curry little fake spin larvas
ottoman hurry adjust beautifully by klay
Thompson Thompson such a good defensive
player James well beyond the arc drills
the three pointer he's been shooting the
three pretty well this season previous
to that three-point us way he's been
tentative against his warriors he that's
where he gets himself into trouble
Durant with sitting right on top of him
Warren comes so easy to this guy well he
has the ball in his hands
he's moving without the ball elevates
eliminates the shot blocking ability but
give Liga's credit James tries another
three
LeBron James brings the Cavs within one
and perhaps his ninth rebound Thompson
that quick release drills the
three-pointer
[Applause]
sorry looks to help out James drives
wants to shoot another three LeBron
James with a couple of threes here of a
third among green hauls in the rebound
Green goes right leggins barrel Tauber
no Paul lays it up and in Liggins is mad
free the rebound curry just 2 of 8 from
the field
klay Thompson delivers its fourth
three-pointer instead of staying
connected to klay Thompson and paid the
price Irving penetration back to
Thompson
what a sweet pass from Kyrie Irving his
7th assist superb job on klay Thompson
the quick release another three for
Thompson
[Applause]
Thompson sets the screen play Thompson
serving drives Oh off the glass with
some English
Clark has come in for goal of state
bourbon
kicks it out to James corner three
that's good three 3-pointers here in the
third for James for overall Institute
Oh draymond Green with a right hand
the other warriors you like what the
scabs are doing last time with jump shot
by Shumpert that time by Jefferson Oh
Kevin Durant wide open space and an easy
dunk
he's got 28 and played through it curry
on the benches you saw now klay Thompson
to the basket left-handed beautiful
touch off the glass
[Applause]
Durant crossover drives goes into
Liggins blocking foul called on Liggins
sister aunt will get a chance for a
three-point play
get no benefit of it down here tonight
on blocked charge costing a very good
number 12
Shawn pull-up
what's it in 33 for Durant timeout
Cleveland as the lead has gotten to 14
one state had started off the fourth
quarter of the run the lead by 14
Richard Jefferson drives into the main
problems of town
like he said anything he gave a look to
Kevin Durant I disagree with this
technical foul helps Tyree urban and he
deserved it to my feet inside Shumpert
got the deflection the Warriors had the
rebound in their hands looks like Durant
had it Liggins back in the game up top
Irving its reporter right side is good
makes it an eight-point game
[Applause]
Irving the crossover
courage is back to loot instant Weston
side draymond Green throws it down
David West with his fifth assist of the
game that's suspended it turned the
whole series hydrogen I don't think they
think that way Earthlings afraid with
another pick three-pointer
they paid by Steph Curry helping
Cornish shooter even set the wild green
curry beautiful pass from draymond Green
Kevin Love
posting up against play Thompson finds
Jefferson
[Applause]
everybody Richard you're 36 now about
Jefferson over Thompson big-time play it
is great to see that mr. Jefferson is
still moving on up
Wow
vintage Jeffersons 103 99 Golden State
by 4
[Music]
draymond Green goes at love shot rolls
around and falls in what has been a
special regular-season game between
these two NBA champion serving the Jade
that's the tenth assist of Kyrie Irving
Shumpert back to urban fakes drives on
Durant
left-handed clogs it up hurry on Irving
Irving the try back to James
Cavalier sleaze
on James dribble penetration to blow by
Dave's taking two guys and finishing at
the rim my goodness
mama there goes that man
they run this play every time passes
side degree and they got that against
Detroit to break the tie the other night
tied again inside goes Derrick Thompson
they've got the piece of it as Durant
comes the other way to curry hurry for
tre Steph Curry from downtown his first
three-pointer check that his second
three of the game tip taken by Iguodala
ahead now but urban steals the back from
Durant
Murphy gets in the paint he packs it in
one-point game it comes urban drives on
Thompson
Irving spins puts up the shot and the
Warriors call timeout patience he wants
to get to his spot not rushing great
defense
uncle drew does it again 14 of his 25
have come here in a fourth quarter
throwing 10 assists
[Applause]